you could now spend a year in an
Indonesian jail if you're caught having
sex outside of marriage it's part of a
new criminal code approved by Parliament
on Tuesday it also bans Couples from
living together before marriage
we've done our best to accommodate all
inputs and concerns but in the end we
have to take a decision a historical
decision to leave the Dutch Colonial
criminal law behind
the law includes a ban on insulting the
president and speaking out against State
ideology and applies to both Indonesians
and foreigners human rights groups say
the legislation suffocates political and
religious freedoms
the new criminal code will create an
atmosphere of fear an atmosphere of one
spying against another neighbor spying
neighbors family members spying another
family member
it will create an atmosphere of fear
among many journalists editors producers
broadcasters and of course media owners
it is no good for the quality of
Journalism the quality of democracy in
Indonesia
the previous draft of the code was
postponed in 2019 after Country-Wide
protests prompted then-president Yoko
udodo to intervene
Indonesia is the world's largest Muslim
nation and has seen a rise in religious
conservatism in recent years
although the laws will not come into
effect for three years there are
concerns about their impact on Indonesia
as an investment and the holiday
destination especially on Islands such
as Bali which millions of tourists visit
every year Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera